and then some sad news yesterday TVs
king of trivia Alex Trebek says that he
will fight and beat advanced pancreatic
cancer the Jeopardy host announces
diagnosis yesterday the 78 year old says
he plans to work during his treatment in
a statement jeopardy producer Sony
Pictures said if anyone can beat this
it's Alex
dr. Tara Narula is here with more on
this Tara good morning good morning
bianna more than 56,000 Americans are
expected to be diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer this year it's an aggressive
disease especially in later stages but
Trebek says he has no plans to let it
stop him
for more than a thousand episodes Alex
Trebek has tested the country's best and
brightest on Jeopardy are you're
signalling device is working on yes
unfortunately they are but now the
longtime TV host will face his toughest
battle this week I was diagnosed with
stage 4 pancreatic cancer now normally
the prognosis for this is not very
encouraging but I'm gonna fight this
stage for pancreatic cancer is the most
advanced type just three percent of
people survived five years still Trebek
promised to beat it with his trademark
wit truth told I have to because under
the terms of my contract I have to host
jeopardy for three more years jeopardy
is in its 35th season under Trebek last
month he told CBS n about the show's
lasting appeal America is a very
competitive society I can do better on
Jeopardy than you oh yeah let's find out
now America's longest-running game show
host is asking his friends family and
fans for their prayers help me keep the
faith and will win pancreatic cancer is
very difficult to detect but research
efforts are ongoing to find options to
diagnose it earlier Wheel of Fortune
host Pat Sajak wrote about Trebek
yesterday I would never bet against him
we are pulling for you
we certainly are everybody loves Alex
Trebek and we all wish him more than
three years certainly yeah Thank You
Tara